what's happening there reject nation
thanks for clicking on it
we're gonna watch two things from venom
let there be carnage today but before i
go into that i got a couple of things to
say one we are going to watch venom this
week so keep a lookout for our immediate
reaction coming out of the theater we're
going to talk at the theater like how we
normally do two heard all them requests
come in we're gonna be covering
squidward this week
it's good game this week very excited to
check it out we know nothing about it
going in blind i mean uh yeah harass us
enough in the thousands so i guess we're
gonna do it so we're gonna watch two
things today what first one is a 30
second tv spot venom nightclub all right
and the second one is uh
cletus breaking out of prison or
something i just dropped them both in
imovie so we're gonna watch them in one
go
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i'm excited for this
oh dude
[Music]
[Music]
awesome nice awesome nice
i've heard this movie
is weird that's all i'm going to say of
what i've heard so far there's like a
special screening and then there's a
premiere
tonight to which many of our colleagues
have been invited to and are going
one
is
yes i've heard it's weird i've heard
it's fun yeah so like looking at this
footage here like him at the nightclub
i'm like i'm a little bit more prepped
for things like that it seems like venom
really wants to be living in the
spotlight here and i loved like the
tension that that scene brought in just
that 30 seconds alone but damn the
effects look so damn good on carnage
they're looking
incredible i read maximum carnage over
the weekend the whole series issues it
is cool to like look at the trailers and
then look here and being like oh yeah
there are some like there's obviously
some changes of course i mean just right
down to when cletus first gets symbiote
and how he breaks out but like the
breakout in prison scene is in line with
the comics for the most part to see like
the parallels of what is being brought
from that comic and into here mainly i
know it's like borrowing from several
elements especially like the venom hero
run by the time he became a hero in san
francisco because they totally skipped
over venom being a villain in this
franchise yeah i want to see some more
shriek but what we've been getting so
far i mean this looks pretty cool i mean
i love the effects i just love the
effects and you know some people think
like i might be just a little too silly
and like whatever man the first one was
silly and i'm all for just an
entertaining time like my expectations
for what venom nother be carnage needs
to be versus what spider-man no way home
needs to be are very different levels i
wouldn't put them on the same pedestal i
think you should i think i ought to have
what they're designed for at some point
we're going to have to keep going same
thing when they do cross over eventually
that's when i'll put them on the same
pedestal for now i'm like hey i'm just
excited to see carnage brought to life
and i hope he does wreak mayhem
everywhere oh yeah absolutely and i mean
i love the tone of that clip with him
breaking out i mean it seems like even
though it is billed as a clip it's still
been heavily cut down of course uh but
you know just yeah the back and forth of
the suspense and playing up the whole
thing with the silhouette and the fog
and everybody in the gallery sort of
freaking out and everything like i am
fascinated test to see what this movie's
actually going to become because yeah
the few things i've heard are along
those lines of like yeah it's really
strange i don't even quite know how i
feel about it yet um and i like that
prospect going into a movie like this
because it gives me at least the hope
that we might see something new fresh
maybe a little off the beaten path and
that's probably going to deliver on at
least the pulp that you want out of this
well i mean even like looking at the
comic over the weekend and grant it's
just one run that i i really committed
to
absorbing in a couple of days venom and
cletus there is something goofy and
campy about them and their dialogue and
the amount of like
exposition and the the
the overabundance
of
just like child like maniacal behavior
that they both sort of have i feel like
tonally when you're telling me
weird and like venom going to the narc
nightclub presenting this like
narcissistic quality like it to me it's
it's spiritually sort of in line
you know maybe not a hundred percent i
haven't read a comic where he goes to a
nightclub and he's like yeah this party
i haven't seen something like that but
there are qualities here and i'm like i
could see
where they got inspired from there to
adapt it here to the big screen so i
don't know you know
i'm not expecting i'm expecting like a b
movie yeah like a high quality bb yeah
like a really fun schlocky movie because
i think that also helps to take the edge
off of the fact that it's not going to
be rated r and it's not going to be as
like nasty as maybe you could get in a
more serious fashion with these
characters if you're in the pg-13 realm
especially i think leaning in to some of
that humor and some of that camp
actually does help yeah and i also think
that the effects just look so much more
visceral and i feel like it'll be
memorable you know that's like an
important thing is that the fight scenes
were not memorable in the last one no
like more of the comedic bits were more
memorable than the fight scenes and and
one thing that i keep having to take
away with this is damn the effects look
so good here yeah like venom looks like
a real monster he does he really does
and like that's what makes me i mean uh
carnage well they both do but yeah
especially carnage like carnage looks
especially vicious and even just like
the personality they're giving his
various tendrils and things like it
really does feel yeah visceral is the
perfect word like really monstrous and
menacing and nasty and so you know you
still pick up some of that harsh sort of
horror tone even though you know it is
offset by like venoms at the club and
everyone's like cool costume bro i will
say though that i often have
expectations and i like set myself i'll
often i know this happens to me quite a
bit i'll do these trailer reactions and
i'll be like here's just what i'm
expecting i'll be satisfied and then i
watch the actual movie and i'm like you
know i got a lot of problems with it
i often find myself in that camp what i
don't think we've heard yet is what
carnage's voice is gonna sound like and
i'm very curious to hear that i did hear
an interview with woody harrelson where
he was talking extensively about how he
was trying to get andy circus to do the
voice for carnage instead of him but
circus insisted that it was him who does
it so i have no idea what carnage's
voice is going to sound like but i love
how the trailers kind of kept that out
of it and leaving it to be a surprise
for the audience
all right guys well thank you so much
for tuning in today sure we got more
vids coming your way no that's it we did
like seven videos in a row that were not
spider-man related yeah count them up
take it go to the videos list proof
subscribe hit that bell look out for our
um squiddy world reactions and uh catch
you guys soon
you